[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa este es el
magazine de france 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy
visitamos brasil donde la polarización
marca la campaña de cara a las
elecciones presidenciales de octubre en
las que el presidente de ultraderecha y
jair bolsonaro aspira la reelección ante
el ex mandatario de izquierda a luiz
inácio lula da silva un seguidor de lula
fue asesinado durante una discusión
política con un bolsón arista y luego
vamos a chile donde el presidente
gabriel boric reemplazó a sus mayores
aliados dentro del gabinete y de esta
manera se mueve a la izquierda moderada
tras el revés sufrido en el plebiscito
cuando los ciudadanos rechazaron la
propuesta de la nueva constitución sin
embargo el presidente reiteró que sigue
en proceso constituyente y visitamos
venezuela donde los deportes
electrónicos conocidos como i esports se
han convertido en una profesión y con
cuentas de ingresos para los jóvenes en
medio de la crisis económica pese a los
problemas conexión y a las fallas en el
servicio eléctrico los gamers
venezolanos han logrado abrirse paso las
contamos desde caracas
por ahora vamos de inmediato a brasil
con nuestra historia principal la
violencia empaña la campaña de cara a
las elecciones presidenciales de octubre
en las que el presidente yair bolsonaro
de ultraderecha aspira a la reelección
ante el ex presidente de izquierda luis
inácio lula da silva quien es favorito
en las encuestas un juez de la corte
suprema suspendió temporalmente varias
facilidades para comprar armas según
argumentó debido al riesgo de violencia
política sin especificar si se refería
el asesinato a tiros en julio del
tesorero del partido de los trabajadores
o al apuñalamiento de un hombre esta
semana durante los actos del
bicentenario que bolsonaro tomó como una
plataforma para hacer campaña el
presidente brasileño convocó a sus
seguidores a hablar netamente de
política en el día de las fiestas
patrias y la oposición y distintos
grupos sociales aseguraron que estas
reuniones sólo fueron para replicar
discursos de odio veamos más en el
informe de juan pabló lucumí
yo soy joris el 7 de septiembre brasil
celebra la independencia de portugal y
bolsonaro convocó a sus seguidores en
varias ciudades del país para criticar a
su contrincante y fortalecer los valores
conservadores pero no realizó ni una
sola mención al día patrio en su
discurso desde la capital dios el
trabajo la familia y las fuerzas
militares fueron la base de su discurso
político
[Aplausos]
aquí no tenemos mentiras de datafolha
aquí está nuestro data pueblo aquí está
la verdad
y aquí está la voluntad de un pueblo
honesto libre y trabajador
sabemos que nos enfrentamos a una lucha
entre el bien y el mal
el mal de lula que duró 14 años en
nuestro país que casi rompe nuestra
patria y que ahora quiere volver a la
escena del crimen
[Música]
la oposición no tardó en criticar al
mandatario el favorito en las encuestas
varios de los otros diez candidatos y
hasta políticos abanderados de derecha
aseguraron que su discurso careció de
argumentos y fue innecesario grupos
feministas señalaron los comentarios
machistas que bolsonaro y la multitud
repetían refiriéndose al presidente como
un hombre muy viril y que satisface
sexualmente a su esposa comentarios que
se escuchaban cada que el mandatario se
refería a la primera dama y según
expertos alimentan la cultura machista
en el caso de lula no convocó a sus
simpatizantes el mismo día realizó la
reunión un día después y desde allí
acusó las acciones de bolsonaro ya muy
chicas algo muy interesante fue que la
demostración de bolsonaro parecía una
reunión del club klux klan sólo le
faltaba el vestuario con la sudadera con
capucha porque no había gente negra
morena o pobre
el más reciente informe de intención de
votos de data folk ya ubica ya ir
bolsonaro 18 puntos por debajo del ex
presidente lula da silva desde que hizo
oficial su candidatura el presidente
brasileño ha realizado varios mítines
políticos para convencer a la población
religiosa y los indecisos mientras
recalca los errores que su contrincante
tuvo durante su gobierno lo que ha
traído una fuerte polarización al país
sudamericano y ha incrementado los
episodios de odio y violencia entre la
población que discrepa entre ambos
bandos
ahora vamos a chile porque el presidente
gabriel boric hizo una reforma profunda
a su gabinete ministerial
sacrificando a dos de sus aliados más
cercanos desde que era líder estudiantil
tras el amplio triunfo del rechazo a la
nueva propuesta de la constitución en el
plebiscito con el cambio el primero en
sus seis meses en el poder moriche
escogió a ministros que son considerados
menos radicales se trata de la ministra
del interior óscar fitch es a quien
reemplazó por carolina tohá y a su
secretario de presidencia giorgio
jackson además anunció la salida de los
ministros de desarrollo social de
familia de salud de energía y de
ciencias y tecnología el mandatario
también anunció que sigue en el proceso
de la nueva constitución
el presidente chileno lo ha calificado
como una de las cosas más difíciles que
ha hecho tan solo 48 horas después del
rechazo de los chilenos a la propuesta
de la nueva constitución gabriel boric
hizo una reforma en el corazón de su
gabinete
y es que a sitges genera administra el
interior cumple un papel crucial durante
la segunda vuelta presidencial que le
dio la victoria al mandatario y quien
tal vez fue la más atacada por la
oposición entregó entre lágrimas su
cargo a carolina tohá y con el objetivo
de acercarse más hacia la izquierda
tradicional movió a su mano derecha
giorgio jackson un viejo amigo y quien
estaba encargado de su agenda
legislativa ahora ocupará un cargo no
tan cercano a la base de su gestión en
la cartera de desarrollo social
moriche también tomó el juramento de los
nuevos ministros de salud energía y
ciencia quiero que sepan
que hago este cambio de gabinete
pensando en nuestro país
es cambio de dieta siempre son
dramáticos en chile
ya éste no le ha faltado su dosis
tenía que volver
y huele pero necesario
es quizás
creo que no tengo por qué esconderlo uno
de los momentos más difíciles
políticamente
no te puedo enfrentar
la oposición esperaba modificaciones la
convocatoria a votar por una nueva carta
magna llegó luego de tres años del
estallido social en el país sudamericano
y pese a que en octubre de 2020 casi el
80 por ciento de los electores votaron a
favor de cambiar la constitución que
data de la dictadura militar de augusto
pinochet más del 60 por ciento de los
votos fueron en contra la propuesta del
documento que se esperaba fuera ahora de
las cartas más progresistas del mundo no
ha sido fácil
pero los cambios nunca son fáciles y
confío en este equipo que me acompaña
para liderar
el reencuentro que tenemos que ejercer
en chile- con el proceso constituyente
que seguirá su curso
y buena atender a las demandas de la
ciudadanía que clama por más presencia
por más respeto por más justicia y por
más igualdad
el gobierno de boris estaba
estrechamente ligado al nuevo texto
doris aseguró que trabajará con el
congreso y diferentes sectores de la
sociedad para tener en cuenta las
peticiones de la gente que consideró muy
radicales algunas de las propuestas
cualquiera que sea el nuevo documento se
espera que sea menos ambicioso que la
carta que se propuso con 388 artículos
hablemos ahora de colombia y venezuela
porque tras siete años de cierre
comercial y vehicular los presidentes
gustavo petro y nicolás maduro
anunciaron la reapertura de las
fronteras a partir del 26 de septiembre
como primer paso se reanudará la
conexión aérea y de transporte de carga
entre ambos países actualmente sólo está
permitido el paso peatonal tras su
llegada al poder el presidente gustavo
petro anunció que restablecería los
lazos diplomáticos con venezuela que
bajo el mando de iván duque no reconocía
a nicolás maduro como presidente
legítimo
seguimos en venezuela porque en medio de
la crisis los deportes electrónicos se
han convertido en una profesión y fuente
de ingresos para los jóvenes pese a los
problemas de conexión y las fallas en el
servicio eléctrico los gamers han
logrado abrirse paso en el mundo de los
videojuegos el informe es de nuestra
corresponsal en caracas daniela zambrano
javier colmenares ganó su primer torneo
regional de videojuegos en mexico en
2017 desde entonces se ha especializado
en formar equipos para competencias
nacionales e internacionales de i
esports y generar contenido en el mundo
de los videojuegos hoy día se han
convertido en una lucrativa fuente de
ingresos
hay muchísimos jugadores profesionales
venezolanos que han llegado a más de 30
mil dólares de links en 6 go creo que el
máximo ha sido han sido 33 mil
y dependiendo de cada juego y depende
también tres oportunidades porque por
ejemplo pueden ser jugadores venezolanos
que ya no viven en venezuela sino que
viven en españa y por ser muy buenos
ficharon con un club durante la pandemia
la comunidad de gamers en venezuela
creció de manera exponencial
este auge sirvió incentivo para que una
universidad inauguraron la primera
academia de spots para profesionalizar a
jugadores y al personal involucrado en
la industria de los videojuegos van a
necesitar abogados van a citar
psicólogos van a visitar coaches van a
necesitar gente que se dedica el
desarrollo ya parte del juego de la
infraestructura de la tecnología y bueno
estamos viendo potencial desde que la
universidad pueda formar venezolanos
talento venezolano para incursionar en
esta industria de forma profesional pero
en venezuela la legislación juega en
contra la denominada ley para la
prohibición de videojuegos y juguetes
bélicos vigente desde 2009 prohíbe
expresamente la promoción de videojuegos
que incitan a la violencia o uso de
armas
gamers como javier y carlos piden
reformar la ley
nada más por no poder promocionar esos
torneos abiertamente o
dedicar algunas sesiones para ver quién
es mejor y tal no lo hace por miedo a
que no los perjudique pues y como te
digo que para que pasen ligo fly / me
pasa en contra striker gente emigra nada
más para poder competir los problemas de
conectividad y fallas en el servicio
eléctrico son una desventaja para los
gamers venezolanos javier pueden horas
de la madrugada cuando hay mejor
conexión a internet sin embargo otros
han decidido emigrar para poder
garantizar mejor conexión en sus
competiciones
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa sigan viendo más en
france24
[Música]